Hello Freak bitches.
What did you,
what is the big thing that you
got out of this personally?
Or sort of intellectual above?
I mean,
intellectually as personally,
right?
Personally,
you know,
there was,
I'd been through sort of lifetime of,
I dunno,
like I was a late bloomer as a kid.
I'm real small,
always sort of the front
of my school came into my,
my throat,
an average sized guy now,
but I came to my growth really
late and so I sort of have a basic,
you know,
schoolboy story about getting
pushed around and bullied and,
and it's,
there's no heroism in that
story that always backed down.
I always ran for it.
I always found some way out of it.
And it wasn't because I was a pacifist.
It wasn't like had some noble high
minded reasons for avoiding the violence.
It was that I was scared and I
knew I was gonna get my ass kicked.
But I've always kind of felt like
that's no excuse for not for fighting,
you know,
that there's a huge,
you should stand up to the bully.
Um,
I've always felt that way and
even though I never did it so,
so,
so part of what I wanted to
do was I wanted to go into
that cage and I wanted to
sort of stand up to guys who were stronger
than me and more skilled than me and
sort of taken those beatings that I felt
like I should have taken 20 years ago.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and so as deep.
Well,
yeah,
you know,
I don't know if you've ever had
experience like that as a boy.
Um,
where were you?
Were you behaved in a fashion
that you define as cowardly?
Yes,
definitely.
And it's amazing to me.
I'm 42 years old now.
I've had a lot of
accomplishments in my life,
have a beautiful wife,
I have little children who are wonderful.
It's amazing to me how much psychological
weight that still carries from me that
I could still meet myself,
blush,
uh,
thinking back to those moments.
And so part of it was a redemption
story for me about whether I could,
whether I could do
something to redeem myself,
at least in my own eyes for those
times when I'd flinched a as a kid.
That's awesome.
I love that.
I love that you did that.
I don't love that.
You're still blushing over it.
Silly social a little bit.
It's so crazy.
But it just means you've got work to do.
That's all it is.
You know,
just kind of worked before you
realize you're not that guy anymore.
Right.
You know.
So when you're doing these heavy,
heavy lifting,
it dead ends,
that impulse,
it slows it down.
And uh,
not,
not to mention you're
neglecting the forefoot.
All these exercises are pretty
much done on the ball on the hill.
I was squatting.
I remember as you're,
you're taught to press through that
heel deadlifting the same thing.
So your,
your,
your training over and over
these movements that are
not practical for a sports
movement,
which pretty much every sport
is played on the forefoot.
Yeah,
that's true.
Like he never really in a sport.
You very rarely push off
the back of the foot,
so kind of moving forward when you're
punching the back heels off the ground.
Absolutely.
And so knowing that it's kind of like,
why are we doing this?
You know,
like w,
W,
it's improper training.
I mean it really makes sense.
Mark has been preaching
this for years and you know,
and people of Scoff at it and you see
now I got to get my heavy back squat and
that's fine,
but maybe this can help you with it.
You know,
start training the feet,
looking at looking at what we're talking
about here and the sequence of muscles
that you're going to start firing
when you do start training the feed,
like how is this a better option for
squatting would be a front squat.
And now let's say you take a couple of
45 pound plates and you put them under
the balls of your feet.
So now you're engaging more of a sports
movie and you're on the balls of your
feet and you're loading up
the front instead of the back,
which is the back squat is
technically a lower back exercise.
It really hits the lumbar
and his lower back a lot.
Uh,
the front squat is going to hit more
quadricep muscles required for jumping,
you know what I mean,
as well as the core and stabilizing
the spine with the abdominals and
everything.
So that's just a thought
like maybe you can do that.
You think,
start thinking in that process where
you're training from the feet up the
forefoot up,
not just the heels of the forefoot up
and you'll start connecting different
muscles require for sports movements.
Okay.
Let's see.
Not a hero and other stuff with Alex.
this is Kevin.
Kevin Right now can crank up the volume,
bro.
Bro Is Kevin.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
This.
Kevin Pereira was the host of attack of
the show for network and the objective
is asking.
He's a very bright man,
didn't as beautiful complexion
and excellent bone structure.
Look at that job line.
Boom.
Happening.
That's the one cop.
Did they dispatch a shot?
That dude in the face so much.
He's got a partner.
Oh,
he's only got a couple of interviews.
Headshot blogs.
You don't let them use that on Ya.
Sorry Bud.
He only has a couple of 100 viewers
because he just got on right watching you
now Kevin.
Oh,
they're saying Joe's watching now.
Fellow Brian read bad and we should go
back to history and and the c nine pro
Gamer guy.
What a weird world we live in
respect to the CS go communities.
So is that Kevin's studio that
we're looking at in the corner?
Yeah,
this is man cave.
This is one part of his studio.
This is where he does all his twitch
gaming and stuff in his podcast.
The first thing you think
of in all these rooms,
it's like where did they rub one out?
Like what part of
the script on you?
Motherfucker.
Rogan.
Alright,
how can we do this?
Let's enter the Matrix.
We can somehow.
There's a lag though.
Unfortunately.
It's probably like seven to 10 seconds.
Look at that.
You just opened the floodgate of racist.
Yeah.
No,
it's always racist stuff for some reason.
That's I subscribers Kevin.
There we go.
Oh,
not logged in.
Then Joe Rogan wants to the studio.
Are you logged in to see your studio?
The studio.
Oh,
how cool.
This is getting way confusing.
This is so bizarre.
It's like two mirrors facing each other.
Who?
Nice Sriracha shirt.
Yes sir.
Get that attorney Kevin Pereira.
Would that get dope studio?
Can we go full screen?
Full screen on the Cam.
Look at that.
Hey Kevin,
we're finally getting to hear you.
Now.
Here's this.
Want that jail.
This is doe.
That experience podcast table Alex
and what we call the band room,
but I don't even know how
we get up to the band room.
Alright.
Can you sprint?
This is a place he's renting.
They need like a USB extension cord.
Walk me.
Look at this.
This is hilarious.
Boy,
this is so bizarre watching Kevin
get out of there.
So we're watching Kevin Pereira
and it's the attack on twitch.
It's getting way confused.
We'll get a gun AC.
You're hearing too far in los looks,
Bro.
Is fucked today backward.
That was brought out.
Wow.
This is very strange studio.
Oh Joe,
just wait.
I'm going to give you the Kevin.
We're finally getting to hear you.
Now.
Here's a student.
This is interesting.
Oh,
so he's freaking me out.
Now we've got the
bar
watching us.
Watching them.
This is fucking.
I think we can time travel somehow.
We just did.
Look what we're doing here.
We're showing his dick
again back to his tablet.
Chose.
Got a full head of hair.
What's good?
This is all so bizarre.
Run.
So this is where he plays pinball,
foods ball.
It's bunch of couches.
There's also has a humongous
green screen on the side.
Here's this kitchen area,
which is like a bar in the middle.
Here's this bar here.
You can just turn it up.
Oh yeah.
So this is joe is a pool table,
like a drink of whatever.
Poison your mind.
Wow.
This is the best room,
right?
Okay.
This is really fascinating.
Oh Kevin,
that's a whole recording studio.
Set up,
messing around already.
Sessions and whatnot.
Oh my God.
This place must be huge.
His keys and guitar.
Joe wrote it out because we have issues
and then so loungy sorta hang out area.
We can also unlatch the barn
doors here and push them out.
It's just push out and we
have room for like 150 people,
so he has shown he has live shows,
concerts and stuff invites his
friends and fam dicks we can allow.
This is crazy.
Kevin Pereira is taken to the next level.